[Music]
now it's time for something fun great
idea
it's been a while since we've gotten to
play a game on this show and i miss it
so
i've come up with a fun little game that
you can play along with at home
it's called buschemi or bird
[Music]
this is the first ever game that asks
you to figure out whether a photo i show
you
is of renowned film and television actor
steve buscemi or
this one bird i saw at a home depot the
rules are simple
you just uh oh amber we have to put a
pause in this
check your phone a report out of florida
says there have been more than 10
000 covet variant cases and the state
has seen a surge
after memorial day all right
i guess buscemi or bird will have to be
pushed to another week
again this was supposed to be a comedy
show
with lots of gags and goofs and laughs
and spoofs that make you go whoa but now
the news keeps getting worse and i was
already
fearing this so no more jokes it's time
for us to get serious
hey amber that skateboard we ordered is
finally here
you know for that sketch john and kate
plus skate
sorry tarik but that way too late parody
is gonna have to wait
we gotta tackle some serious news oh
okay
[Music]
go bid numbers rising means there's no
time for silliness
i can't wear funny wigs if the police
won't stop killing us
so no more smiling save your bunny ha
has for the night time
i have to google what's up with this
pipeline
yeehaw partner well i reckon we got
ourselves a little battery
we actually have to cut this character
we want to do a speech addressing the
rise of white supremacy in the united
states
that doesn't sound very funny yeah it's
not but if you want you can come on at
the end playing a skinhead
can you be a cowboy skinhead no that's
ridiculous just a regular skinhead
i'll go shave i guess
[Music]
rocket ships from outer space might
crash and kill us all
and fauci says we might be wearing mass
still in the fall
california had its 12th mass shooting
did you know
that number's probably gone up since we
wrote this days ago
i'm a singing soda and i'm shaking my
can okay hey
no sorry corinne we actually have to cut
this sketch
there have been some really awful things
happening in the news so we got to
address them
you can go home but i learned an entire
broadway dance number for this
sorry i'm not a dancer it took weeks can
i just like
just show you a little just no corrin
put your arms down
it's time to get serious
one day things might simmer down and
then we'll all get silly
we'll finally shoot that bit we rode
with dunk tanks full of chili
but till then we'll do good with all the
power we have harnessed
and use our show to lighten up the
darkness uh
amber scotland's just got shot yeah
apparently some real skinheads didn't
like his impression of him
oh we can't do anything on this show
you